[Music]
from John wick to John Wayne gunfights
in movies can often look so real that
it's hard to imagine how they're put
together here at the British action
academy stuntman and respite readers
teaches students how to safely perform
firearm sequences we do gum rush today
which is far off for film course which
teaches people about the performance
side of using firearms on a filter my
background I've been a stuntman for
about 28 years now I've worked on you
know many many productions Star Wars RW
& McGregor in all the lightsaber fights
and obviously trained you and on Bond
films I've done both I've trained the
actors and also I've played characters
myself and I've doubled characters in
the old days of course people used to
actually get shot
nowadays though films use a series of
dummy replacements there are blanks real
working weapons loaded with blank
cartridges these are for when you just
need a big muzzle flash or a loud bang
function guns a replica guns that don't
actually fire or for cheaper fake
versions that don't look as real in a
close-up some movies use rubber guns the
person responsible for these on a set
the weapons master and stunt performers
need to know exactly how to use them the
thing with blanks is that they do not
still make a lot of noise and you get
the kind of flash as well that you
expect from a gun shot so it's a really
realistic experience for actors it's all
about selling the idea that it's a real
gun
that's a big step stay down come up do
two shots they don't you're gonna do
what hands in front of you
get into cover back back now we're on
the right leg
they don't like the same way and of
course reacting to being shot is
important when you do multiple reactions
that's when it gets tricky
who's your timing and tempo you've got
to do actually gonna do it
[Music]
they teach you the way is to kind of
roll onto your body so you don't just
smack the floor but it does still kind
of hurt like these guys they don't mess
about one thing that can be very real is
the weight of the equipment actors have
to lug around
according to Andreas actors on the set
of Saving Private Ryan warp axe weighted
down with ammo all in the name of
believability
the prop guns themselves go hand in hand
with sound design when a gun fires
you're hearing three acoustic elements
the muzzle blast sound at the impact
point and the crack sound of the bullet
traveling through the air without this
layering a movie just doesn't seem as
realistic
cinema is filled with basic gun mistakes
[Music]
so how would a beginner go about getting
it right my advice to anybody who wants
to get into the industry as a stunt
performer is its dedication you know
it's part of your life you but I really
want to do it it's not not a part-time
hobby and the more skills you have under
your belt the more employable you are
[Music]